Digamos que tengo 3 enteros,
muy bien, y tengo 3 enteros
que les voy a poner nombre,
se llaman "a", "b" y "c",
además estos enteros
son números positivos,
eso quiere decir que
son números naturales esencialmente
¿ok?
Y estos tres enteros,
estos tres números dijimos que son,
enteros,
muy bien,
además tenemos otra información,
tenemos que "a" más "b"
si lo dividimos entre "c"
también es un número entero,
también es entero,
muy bien, y eso no siempre pasa
¿verdad?
Entonces
esta expresión es un entero,
pero no sólo eso,
también tenemos otra propiedad,
que "a" es un múltiplo...
es múltiplo de "c".
Ok,
o bien esto es lo mismo que decir,
que "a" es divisible....
es divisible,
entre "c",
es divisible entre "c",
esto es exactamente lo mismo,
que "a" es múltiplo de "c"
o que "a" es divisible entre "c", es decir,
que si "a" yo lo divido entre "c",
eso nos da
exactamente un número entero.
Entonces la pregunta para todos es la siguiente
¿Será cierto que "b"
tiene que ser un entero?
Tiene que ser perdón...
sí es un entero, pero
¿Tiene que ser un múltiplo de "c"?
¿Será cierto que "b"
tiene que ser múltiplo de "c"?
Y aquí nuevamente te recomiendo
que hagas una pausa en el vídeo
para que pienses tú tu propia respuesta,
cómo explicarías tú si "b"
puede ser un múltiplo de "c"
o tiene que ser un múltiplo de "c"
o
puede que sí, puede que no...
¿Ok? Entonces ya que le diste una pausa
y que estamos de vuelta,
vamos a pensar
muy bien en este problema.
Vamos a reescribir esta expresión
"a" más "b" entre "c"
es un entero,
entonces vamos a reescribirlo porque
"a" más "b" sobre "c"
podemos utilizar la distributividad
y expresarlo como
"a" entre "c" más "b" entre "c",
muy bien
Entonces sabemos que esta suma es un entero,
esto de aquí es un
entero,
muy bien
Esto de aquí todo completo es un entero
pero no sólo eso,
sabemos que "a" es un múltiplo de "c"
y eso significa o bien que si "a"
es divisible entre "c",
quiere decir que yo al dividir
"a" entre "c"
esto me queda un número entero,
también es un entero éste sumando.
Entonces date cuenta de lo siguiente,
tengo un entero que le estoy sumando algo
y nos da un entero,
así que si eso pasa,
pues ese algo tiene que ser un entero,
así que
esto de aquí "b" entre "c"
también tiene que ser un entero,
también...
también tiene que ser entero...
También es entero,
muy bien,
entonces
fíjate que si "b" lo dividimos entre "c"
nos resultó ser un entero,
¡Ah! Pues eso es justamente la definición
de ser un múltiplo de "c" ¿verdad?
que al dividirlo entre "C"
nos dé un entero.
Así que para que eso,
para que eso sea cierto,
lo que debe pasar es que
"b" es múltiplo de "c", entonces,
partimos de 3 enteros positivos,
muy bien,
si sumábamos los 2 primeros
y los dividíamos entre "c"
resultaba ser entero
y también sabíamos que "a" es un múltiplo de "c",
entonces, utilizando esas propiedades,
separamos esta expresión en una suma,
y si el primero es entero
y nos daba entero,
pues el otro tenía que ser entero.
Así que en este caso
"b" es un múltiplo de "c",
así que si nos preguntan
¿"b" tiene que ser un múltiplo de "c"?
Nosotros podemos responder sí,
sí lo es.